aujourd'hui une vidéo peu particulière
puisque je vous emmène dans le passé je
vous emmène découvrir des nouvelles
lunettes connectés de buzz en
partenariat avec boulanger c'est une
vidéo que j'ai tourné à new york avant
la crise du coronavirus elle que je vous
diffuse uniquement maintenant vous
comprendrez donc à ce moment là et bien
il faisait un peu moins chaud j'avais
abonnés on né le 5 mars 2020 je vous
ramène à new york découvrir les lunettes
collecte et de buzz et ça me fait un
bien fou de vous ramener à new york
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai un problème elle du
soleil pour à new york
je veux mettre les ya du soleil je vais
écouter de la musique
sakai gimont bonnet je fais comment les
lunettes vous connaissez j'aime est
comme ça la musique vous connaissez
mon casque je pose comme ça mais là
c'est la merde je n'entends plus rien
c'est la pose pas je monte mon bonnet
comme ça comme ça là c'est pas trés
idéal pour remplacer des lunettes de
soleil et un casque bose j'ai une
solution est la solution c'est ça tout
simplement alors s'assurer une état
audio cascade de bosses s'appelle
boyfriend ça se positionne comme ça en
fait ce sont des lunettes de soleil
connecté en bluetooth à votre smartphone
wave ce que vous voulez et ça vous
permet d'écouter la musique partout vous
voulez en ayant les oreilles libre les
oreilles dégagé
[Musique]
alors comment savoir ce truc en fait
c'est hyper simple et non d'une aide
soleil que vous allez connecté en
bluetooth à votre smartphone comme
n'importe quel casque bluetooth jusque
là vous connaissez c'est très très très
très facile vous avez des hauts parleurs
qui sont hyper directives qui sont
planqués en dessous de chaque côté
petite batterie à l'intérieur bonjour
pas ce truc vous le recharger en le
connectant directement et le truc qui
est lâchement couleur fait si vous
voulez c'est que vos petits haut
parleurs ils sont extrêmement directif
avec un chantier pas très fort mais qui
est largement suffisant pour vos
oreilles
le truc est vraiment défendre c'est que
la qualité audio elle est complètement
incroyable on s'attendrait à voir un
truc un peu cheap aberration qu'est
bataile c'est tout le contraire le son
est vraiment la bonne qualité on a une
expérience qui vraiment cool vous balai
dans la rue les oreilles complètement
découvert garde et j'appuie la tacc j'me
mêle musique là vous entendez pas mais
j'ai les beatles en mai auraient ça joue
quand même relativement fort du coup je
parle fort vous appuyez vous mettez la
poste vous appuyé deux fois morceau
suivant trois fois manceau précédent on
vous passe un coup de fil vous appuyez
vous décrochez vous appuyez vous
raccrochez vous avez un seul et même
bouton très très très très facile et
doit pas dû purement expérientiel c'est
vraiment cool
on n'a pas du gros grave qui ronronne on
n'a pas beaucoup beaucoup de basques
c'est normal on est tous par leur
extrêmement déshérités par contre pour
tous qui médiums et aigus et la qualité
quand même au rendez-vous bien
évidemment on n'aura pas une qualité
aussi bonne que ce qu'on peut avoir avec
les derniers casques de bosses notamment
les casques à réduction de bruit mais
par contre pour vous balader en mains
libres dans la rue vous pouvez aller
faire du sport pouvait aller courir vous
entendez ce qui se passe autour de vous
c'est une voiture qui klaxonnent vous
l'entendez vous pouvez également parler
à quelqu'un vous mettez la musique pas
trop forte si vous voulez parler à
quelqu'un sinon voulons tendre est
absolument plus mais voyez vous êtes
comme ça dans la rue tranquillement les
oreilles découvert vous avez votre
musique avec une qualité audio qui est
franchement cool et moi je vous saviez
vous pouvez aller faire du running vous
pouvez courir avec sans aucun problème
vous mettez votre petit bonnet vous
recouvrez vos oreilles vous êtes quand
même hyper attentif à ce qui se passe
autour de vous en termes de sécurité
qualité pour moi vous un produit qui est
vraiment top
[Musique]
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là lorsqu'on
parle bien évidemment de lunettes de
soleil ou des lunettes qui vous protège
contre le soleil c'est quand même la
base principale de lunettes de soleil
peut d'aucune protection contre les
rayonnements uv à uv b
vous pouvez donc vous balader par beau
temps comme l'a par exemple à new york
il faut un temps assez incroyable il
fait super bon accueil à peu du petit
bonnet mais c'est plutôt cool parce que
mes yeux sont protégés contre les rues
soleil donc 2.0 ça fait vraiment à fond
mais vous pouvez également passer des
coups de fil très facilement parce que
vous avez un micro intégré au total au
cutter va donc pouvoir vous entendre
très facilement vous allez pouvoir
l'entendre alors attention vous risquez
de passer pour un sou dans la rue
puisque on vous voit avec des lunettes
de soleil on vous voit sans écouteurs
vous marchez vous paraît tout seul on va
vous prendre pour un taré mais c'est pas
grave il existe deux modèles de ses
lunettes vous avez le modèle alto ses
modèles couché sur la tête tout de suite
vous avez deux tailles une taille small
medium et une taille médium l'astre
d'écran la tête de chacun moi
personnellement j'écoute une petite tête
les coûts d'une telle paire de lunettes
darwich
tic tac de lunettes vaut mieux il ya
aussi le modèle rondot qui est un peu
plus rond avec une seule taille cette
fois ci c'est la taille small medium
bien évidemment il ya l'expérience audio
bien évidemment vous êtes protégé contre
v avec bébé
c'est
et lorsque vous payez sur la tête vous
sentez pas les haut parleurs situe ici
vous la verrez vous le voyez ici haut
parleurs là c'est extrêmement directive
vous avez la même chose évidemment de
l'autre côté le petit bouton pour dire
l'allumer et l'éteindre c'est celui là
et là vous avez les connecteurs la voyez
qui sont planqués juste ici pour venir
recharger leur connecteur c'est très
simple vous avez se connectera qui est
un petit port propriétaire bose et d'un
côté vous avez un connecteur en usb pour
brancher dans n'importe quel match et
vous avez un verre qui est protégé
contre les chocs et contre les rayures
on a une compatibilité bauza r vous avez
une portée de neuf mètres en bluetooth
et bien évidemment vous avez vos
assistants vocaux dessus que ce soit
google assistance soit amazon est exact
que ce soit syrie pour l'appeler ceux
qui depuis longtemps sur le petit bouton
ici quentin appuyons tient venir
l'appeler pour lui parler pour lui
demander n'importe quel comment ce que
vous voulez ça marche pas très bien et
c'est extrêmement facile à utiliser leur
bien évidemment qui dit série qui dit
gurria citant qui dit amazon axa dit que
vous avez une application derrière
compatible ios mais également android
quoi maintenant
ouais ça ce soir nous annonce 3h30
d'autonomie
on est là dedans entre 3h30 et 4h
d'ecoute prolonger la recharge c'est
quelque chose comme deux heures bon
c'est pas là dessus qu'on va dans la
meilleure autonomie mais c'est pas
anormal vu la taille de la machine
néanmoins pour venir vous balader les
petites les sons comme ça ça marche
avons voulu faire des grosses grosses
grosses balade de quelques heures nous
mais bon dans l'absolu c'est pas
forcément ce cas cela qu'il vous faudra
pour voir qu'on n'a pas des petits
écouteurs pouvoir comptera pas des bugs
pouvoir qu'on n'a pas des intra on a
quand même une spatialisation qui est
plutôt bonne pas particulièrement de
distorsion alors qu'elle que si vous
mettez du métal à fond évidemment vous
pourrez avoir un peu de distorsion ce
qui est bien avec ses lunettes casque si
vous n'êtes pas besoin de pousser le son
a profité d'une bonne expérience
autre point qui est cool c'est que les
verts sont interchangeables maintenant
je dois envoyer en principal de ce
produit c'est que si vous êtes il ya
beaucoup de bruits environnants vous
êtes dans un métro quelque chose comme
ça vous avez beau pousser le son à fond
vous avez les oreilles dégager ça vient
pas les bloquer donc c'est pas
complètement génial mais ça ne paraît
pas anormale du point de vue
expérientiel la nuit
côté tarif on est sur des lunettes qui
coûte 229 euros 95
on est sur un tarif un peu intermédiaire
sur des lunettes de soleil de qualité
c'est une somme mais pour un service
rendu trouve que le tarif et condamnent
vos lunettes sont livrés dans cette
boîte
ça ce sont les frames alto vous ouvrez
vous retrouver à l'intérieur ce petit et
de suite dans lesquelles sont vos
lunettes dont je les ai enlevés il ya
évidemment garder c'est quand même pas
mal
il a une qualité de tissu qui est
premium vous avez ici votre petit câble
pour venir leur charge et vous les
mettez dedans vous fermez votre pas la
rage comme moi mais vous le mettez
certains moi je vois pas mal le boulot
qui a été fait par bose même au niveau
de la conception l'étui vous avez à
l'intérieur ici ou petit dock qui vous
explique comment ça marche vous allez
voir franchement c'est pas très
compliqué et pour tout comprendre très
facilement vous avez une application
boss connect qui vient se connecter
directement à vos lunettes dont claire
connais mes lunettes elle propose même
d'ailleurs une petite mise à jour du
produit
j'ai quelques paramètres on va voir le
nom de mes lunettes
la connexion la présentation du produit
ça c'est pas mal parce que ça vous
explique vraiment comment ça marche
comment venir le connecter comment
écouter de la musique comment sauter un
titre comment répondre à un appel mettre
hors tension white c'est très facile
comment les recharger on vous prend
vraiment par la main là dessus
la programmation de la mise en veille
les invitations vocal la langue
un petit mode d'emploi donc vous avez
tous dans cette appli alors bien
évidemment ici pas d quoi les hommes on
va pas venir chercher ça avec ce type
d'application de toute façon se servir à
rien de venir mettre un équaliseur là
dessus et vos lunettes lorsque vous les
éteindre c'est très facile vous les
prenez vous les basculer voulez mais à
l'envers
hélas elles sont éteintes pour les
allumer c'est aussi facile vous les
prenez vous appuyez sur le fameux petit
bouton vous avez là et là c'est parti
voilà concédait de soleil connectés de
bosses dites moi ce que vous en pensez
comment vous les trouvez vous ce que
vous aimez ce
système de lunettes de soleil oreilles
libre pour écouter de la musique
les boys prime si elle vous intéresse
vous aimez bien évidemment un lien en
bas dans la description pourrait me dire
ce que vous en pensez moi je trouve
plutôt intéressante vous avez donc bien
évidemment comme d'habitude a laissé des
jolies pousse à vous abonner parce qu'on
va continuer à parler tech plein de
choses à raconter
et puis des jolis produits comme ça un
petit peu atypique il y en a plein moi
je trouve ça cool à regarder là les
oreilles libre j'écoute de la musique
ici à new york
tout va bien sur ce je vous embrasse
donne rendez vous demain pour étudier
par les tracts des vidéos
[Musique]